you died a lot Teresa died a lot in this
film strides 17 or 18 times I think it
was after I counted it could have even
been more I know I really liked the
drowning sequence when I'm in cameo
everything here I get golden I think
that that one's oh no but your favorite
is the bus my favorite was the bus and
that was funny but you I mean there's
there's some merit to your answer there
that drowning one was pretty hilarious
the bus one I like is it's just that
quarrel it's it's very plain hanging was
our favorite that's why it's the best
stuff because it's the it's where she
takes back her power I think she says
this isn't gonna happen I guess for yeah
yeah exactly yeah okay what was the
worst way to go out for her though
fountain it was freezing cold that night
it was miserable and she had to get
dunked in that nasty water if you're
gonna we had to like constantly keep
trying to keep her warm and it was it
was really tough really tough that
really tough that was Osmund Osmund so
with this being such an intricate film
what were the challenges that you guys
came up with it he's afraid very low
budget so there was very little time to
make it right so that's the biggest
challenge for sure yet no budget in very
little time
yeah well don't well those two things go
together if it's if they live in movies
low budget there's not a lot of time
that always makes everything much harder
it's a very ambitious movie for its
budget size and so you know we have a
lot of locations we had a lot of effects
we had a lot of practical effects and
stunts and you know you know we've got
explosions and we've got a lot of stuff
in this movie that that you typically
don't see
movie with this type of budget so what
would be the top three reasons that your
view is happier on what she's going to
be number one because it's fun yes
you're number two
scary number two is because it's scary
and number three we'll do it together
because it's really fun
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]